Now let's take a look at Unreal Engine's Live Link plugin with Maya.
Now we'll look at an overview of the concept, understanding the pipeline and just how we
go about setting it up.
Live Link, if you've not heard of it before, is a way to stream your animation from Maya
into Unreal Engine.
Now this allows you to animate directly inside Maya and through the use of Live Link preview
what it will look like inside the engine in real time.
Now this is great because you get to see how your character looks with all the materials
and the lighting and any extra elements on them like cloth that might be applied to them
without having to go through the export and import process.
When it comes to understanding the pipeline of Live Link, you have a plugin for both Maya
and for Unreal that you either need to download or just simply activate.
And in Maya you would define the skeleton that you're using and the character's data
that you want to send over to Unreal Engine.
And then this goes through the Unreal message bus, which is basically a direct channel to
the Live Link client within your Unreal project.
Now the Live Link client manages a couple of things.
So it manages the sources of data that are coming in, which represent the connections
to other programs like Maya or MotionBuilder that can send data to Live Link.
And it also manages the subjects, which is to say the individual streams of data within
the client.
An example of that would be animation information going through for one character.
Now this information is then used in conjunction with a Live Link animation node inside your
animation blueprint to convert that data into animation data on the character in the engine.
Some of the component features of Live Link in Unreal Engine 5 are the Live Link controller
and the skeletal animation components.
Now the controller component is a quick way of taking the Live Link data and applying
that to an actor in your scene.
So as you can see in the example we've got below, this might be taking the transform
information and applying that to a camera to aid something like a virtual production
environment that you're in.
We've also got the skeletal animation component.
So this sits inside your blueprint and gives you access to the onLiveLinkUpdated event,
which effectively takes place of your tick event, but it runs at editor time as well.
So you don't need to be playing or simulating to make use of that data.
You can also access the Live Link data via several blueprint nodes to gather and use
various bits of information like curve data or metadata and different types of transform
information.
So now that we've taken a look at some of the features that overview the pipeline of
Live Link, let's take a look at how to actually get it set up and connect Maya with Unreal
Engine to see your animation streaming live.
So the first thing you'll need to do is go to the Epic Games Marketplace and download
the Unreal Live Link for Autodesk Maya plugin.
Once you've downloaded this, you need to install it to Maya.
Now to load your plugin in Maya, if you've not done this before, if you go to Windows,
down to settings and preferences, and then into your plugin manager, you'll get a list
of plugins that are already installed on your machine that you can sort of load, activate
or deactivate.
But if you've not had one installed before and you need to install something new like
the Maya Live Link plugin, you should have a browse option.
Now if you click the browse option and find the folder where the plugin was saved, you
need to load two different plugins, one called Maya Live Link plugin and then the date, which
may not be 2017 anymore, .ml and then the Maya Live Link UI Python plugin.
Now once your plugins are installed and loaded, to access the Live Link UI, you would use
the melinput command, Maya Live Link UI.
Now you'd put that into your mel line at the bottom of the screen or into your script editor.
You can then save that as a button to your shelf just to make accessing it easier each
time.
Now this UI is where you'd add or remove subjects whose data you want to send over to Live Link
in your Unreal Engine project.
Now to do that, you just choose add selection and you'd select your mesh and root bone of
the character you'd like to stream to Unreal.
But before you can do that, we need to ensure that the plugin is enabled in your Unreal
project.
So by default, the Live Link plugin should be available in a UE5 project, but if it's
not for any reason and you're using an older version of the engine maybe, you can download
it in the same way that you did with the Maya plugin using the Epic Marketplace.
Now you can check if it's loaded by going to your plugins window and searching for Live
Link and just making sure that it's ticked.
And once you have it loaded, you'll have access to a new window inside Window, Virtual Production
called Live Link.
And inside this window, this is where you'll be controlling the Live Link sources and it'll
show you a connection to your DCC like Maya or Motion Builder.
Now something to be aware of and something you should check in your project settings
would be the use less CPU when in background option.
Now if that's turned on, it will inhibit the use of the Live Link when you're working in
Maya.
So if you're tapped out working in Maya, you won't be able to see the animation streaming
live.
So make sure you disable that.
Now to add your source, which would be the information coming from Maya, for example,
you just hit the plus source button, go to Message Bus Source, and you should see a list
of sources matching the selections that you added in Maya.
Now that the Live Link connection is made, you can start to preview the animation on
your character by opening up the corresponding skeletal mesh inside Unreal Engine.
And you should have a new option underneath the animation preview controller drop down
Live Link Preview Controller just inside your Preview Scene Settings tab.
Now if you select this and then change the Live Link subject name just underneath to
match that of your character in Maya, you should see your skeletal mesh begin to match
the animation of your Maya character.
Now something that can be useful as well is to tick the Enable Camera Sync option in the
same Preview Scene Settings tab so that when you move your camera in Maya, the camera in
Unreal should mimic that.
And that should be it.
You should now be able to animate your character in Maya and preview it on your skeletal mesh
in your Unreal project.